die auf das spannende bei der garde ist
die abwechslung einerseits wird in
österreich mit dem bundespräsidenten und
am nächsten tag finden und einem einsatz
oder eingewechselt
[Musik]
ich habe das spiel war gerade ist nicht
nur dass wir im inland gefragt sind auch
im ausland tätig sind sei es über die
auslandseinsätze wie mali kosovo in
bosnien aber auch über die grenzen
hinweg immer wieder bei der präsentation
seiten von anderen ländern eingeladen
werden und dadurch wirken
vollkommen egal ob bei der
repräsentation oder im feld ihr habt
einen dermaßen anspruchsvollen und
komplexen aber auch für den job es war
ein wunderschöner tag bei euch ich danke
noch mal ganz herzlich übrigens für
einen tag war kein mitglied der garde
und hab so viel gesehen was sie können
was sie drauf hat sich stehe immer noch
einigermaßen aber du bist bei sorgen
können nachträglich ist perfekt
verlangen müssen noch sehr jungen
verlässt darf ich hier noch alles
erinnerung an uns deshalb mussten wir
schon jetzt bin ich komplett in sich
[Musik]